you know it ain't easy being young black
people in the neighborhood where they
don't expect us to do anything
thank you sir boom boom boom boom
[Music]
he must work at a rock climbing gym he's
gonna go back home he's gonna be
but he's gonna know he's gonna know that
he has potential
like this usually you in a dark place
and you don't see it that's a clip from
the new documentary black ice
the film follows a rock climbing group
that's made up of mostly black climbers
notable in a sport where diversity is a
challenge
they're from one of memphis tennessee's
most disadvantaged neighborhoods
their excursion ice climbing in montana
was for some both a first attempt at
scaling ice
and a first trip out of memphis the
black eye story isn't just about the
physical journey on the mountain though
it also shares personal transformations
while raising questions about race and
opportunity
[Applause]
welcome to memphis rocks
an oasis in its south memphis
neighborhood of soulsville
helping its community reach summits
never imagined
it's just not like a black rock climbing
gym this is just a rock climbing where
everybody's invited
chris dean has been apart from the
beginning working with its founder who
has
family ties to memphis hollywood
producer tom shadiak
known for films like ace ventura pet
detective and the nutty professor
we went around was trying to find the
right sport to give the
opportunity to this community and after
finding out more about rock climbing and
like facing your fears and
you know pushing yourself it was all
about grit and that's what we have we
have
grit it's the grind city it just felt
right memphis rocks uses a pay what you
can model
so when salacio blackstone first came in
a few years ago
he earned his climbing hours by
volunteering
don't be real though like the gym
changed my life
four years ago still in high school
salacio was shot
multiple times one of the bullets
traveled up his neck and threw his mouth
knocking his bottom teeth out the fourth
oldest in a family of 10 kids
two of salacio's brothers are in jail
right now
the staff here it's like family for real
to me could
one for them i'll be in the streets
right now to this day
and that's what i'll be doing right
there i'll be locked up a day
back for our expedition and you'll have
all your kid in there oh yeah
instead salacio was part of a group of
climbers from memphis rocks
whose trip to ice climb in montana
became the documentary
black ice it's part of real rocks
an annual climbing documentary film
festival now in its 15th year
i've been climbing for 40 years since
what i do it's my passion
never have i seen anything as cool as
memphis rocks
legendary mountaineer conrad anchor
first visited memphis rocks back in
2018.
in february of 2020 memphis rocks
came to anchor he'd lead the black ice
expedition
for me to be in a climbing film and not
climb but to have it be a
a statement about society that we can
learn from was
one of the most meaningful things i've
been in my climbing career
i hate it for five days they camped
so this is what we're climbing this is
it
and climbed the frozen waterfalls of
montana's highlight canyon
the idea with ice climbing was that's
just so
unlike what one would experience in
south memphis so it was a challenge and
there's also a commonality that the cold
and that environment
brings the team together
ice climbing is a whole nother thing the
first day was hard on everybody
there's a few people who like made it to
the top i wasn't one of them
among those documenting the journey
memphis rock's climber
and video journalist jonathan malik
martin
while you were filming this did you
realize
what you had on your hands not really
all i'm
trying to do is the same thing i've been
doing for the past eight years is like
tell the stories of my friends around me
and it's those stories which martin
captured and was
part of that make black ice about more
than
just the climb do i refer you as black
or african-american or
or not at all or is there i like black
yeah you can say okay
yeah they're my black friends it was
important for conrad to ask that
question
is him stating that he does not know and
he wants to learn how to engage with us
in a you know in a healthy manner
black ice also raises questions about
race
and opportunity was there intent behind
that
in filming this no so like even with the
film being called black ice is just
me and my comrade chris dean cracking
jokes back and forth
i really hope ain't no black ice on this
road why everything that's bad got the
name
black like they like black ice and how
you know it's black
it looked clear to me clear to me
exactly you know the absurdity of how
you know just in like how we use
language language is coded
we didn't think about it having that
like you know it being that so much of a
social commentary at the time
like in this moment where the group is
setting up camp
we're out at the woodshed splitting wood
and celestia is rolling around in the
snow
plane
it's coming from memphis where you have
to have an outer shell of hardness to
protect yourself to a kid who's making
snow angels and rolling around flopping
around
and you don't have a worry in the world
because there's nothing out here that's
going to harm you
this community don't let you show no
fear you have to wear you know your
angry black man face you got to be like
look hey
don't try me and that's every day not
today every day and so
so that's why you saw salacio explode
with happiness and and like
energy and like playfulness because he
got a chance to leave memphis he get to
be
12 year old slater you get to be 15 year
olds later get to be
you know playful and that was beautiful
to see
[Applause]
and for salacio who turned 20 on that
mountain
[Applause]
it wasn't just the moment but the entire
trip
that stayed with him i feel so happy
that
my soul was free for once for all the
drama
for all the chaos going on that chill
i finally realized the person who i am
now
i'm a leader not i'm following nice
good job sasho what do you hope someone
who watches
black ice gets out of it i hope that
when somebody watches black ice they get
an immense amount of joy creativity you
know feeling the perseverance
heart of mine
if i still like to be
you know life is is fighting through and
you know the obstacles that lie before
us
and sometimes horrific things can happen
to us
but as long as we're still breathing um
i believe that we got a chance to get it
right
that is strong man you're almost there
[Music]
[Applause]
so i got to tell you guys christine one
of the people we heard from in there
said it's not about the summit
it's about what you bring back from the
summit encouraging people to take that
and travel as well
this memphis rocks gym where they
started at is an incredible place
in itself and the documentary has even
more than what you just saw there you
can find it
on the real rock website it's www.real
real 35 minutes i am telling you
you've got to see this i'm going to
watch it this afternoon i can't wait
it's good stuff david i loved all the
social commentary it is the conversation
that i remember having with friends it's
real it's
real and that's what makes a difference
and it's so honest especially white and
black
yeah thank you dana thank you great
story